hey dr. Berg here I want to share with
you an exciting new seminar that I'm
going to be doing October 3rd called
acupressure for body types acupressure
is not acupuncture there's no needles
involved it's using manual therapy to
get certain parts of your body to work
better so yes you have nutrition you
have died at you have exercise but this
takes it to the next level there are
four main parts that we're going to
cover the first one is how to use
acupressure to maximize maximize stress
extraction from your body there are
certain parts of your body that are
holding the majority of stress and you
could get an hour of massage compared
with a couple minutes of this and have
the equivalent stress extraction because
most of the stress in your body is
located in certain parts so we're going
to show you where they are and what to
do to extract that to maximize
delta-wave sleep because it's in the
sleep where you burn the fat is where
the sleep is where you rejuvenate so if
you're not sleeping is because certain
parts of your body are stuck on and they
won't turn off
so we're going to show you how to do
that with this one this is all about
just you know making you feel less
stress and also getting you to sleep
number two gland
balancing you have certain endocrine
glands in the body of the pancreas you
have the thyroid you have the adrenal
you have the ovary and there's other
glands too well you can use acupressure
to influence these glands in a big way
why because these glands are many organs
that release that send hormones into the
system and retrieve hormones so they're
part of the communication system called
the endocrine system so when you use
manual therapy or acupressure on the
gland system you increase the
communication lines within that system
so it's very very very powerful I don't
think people realize that these glands
can be rejuvenated but they can so we're
going to teach you how to apply it to
the Glen now if you had a heavy let's
just take for example if you had a heavy
period or crampy cycle and hopefully at
the seminar there will be several people
there I can demonstrate this if not I'll
have other videos
to demonstrate it but within minutes you
can take that person and pull them out
of that discomfort or let's say someone
is a hot flash you can apply it to that
or in a stress State you can apply to
that and part of this will also help
this as well
okay next one is instant pain relief
this is the technique that I developed
over 25 years of just trial and error
working on tens of thousands of people
we're going to show you how to apply
this as well so if you or a family
member has this had some chronic pain or
what's called systemic pain which is
pain all over
it's called fibromyalgia I'm going to
show you what to do to get rid of it
instantly the key is if the problem
doesn't resolve right away then you
don't have the right problem you have to
I'm going to show you the system of
finding out where the cause is so you
can create an effect on the effect and
most people they treat the symptom we
want to get to the root cause so we're
going to show you how to do this in a
very simple way and we'll do lots of
demonstration like a lot of the pain
that people have is not coming from
where they have the pain it's being
referred from somewhere else
we're going to teach you that system in
detail and it's a great way to help
people okay so now we have the last one
which is body symmetry if you analyze a
body most people have a front and back
side aside they are so not symmetrical
they're so out of balance you have
certain parts of your body that are too
tight other parts of the body too loose
like the hamstring the back muscle the
neck so this is all about balancing all
the muscles and all of the joints in the
body very quickly so you can actually be
very symmetrical and again this pulls
stress on the body so if you're
interested in helping others if your
purpose is to help others this is a
powerful tool to be able to learn and
apply to your friends and family the
only thing that I ask is once we teach
you this is that you don't teach it to
other people you can apply it to
yourself and family members or friends
but I don't want anyone teaching this
unless they're certified as a
practitioner okay so for more from
click below I hope to see at the seminar